Hagamos algunos problemas de
desigualdades compuestas
y estos son problemas de desigualdades que tienen más de un conjunto de restricciones,
ya verás de qué estoy hablando en un segundo,
así que vamos directamente a un ejemplo
y así que, el primer problema que tengo
es -5 es menor o igual que "x" menos 4,
que es menor o igual que 13
y aquí claramente se ve donde están
las dos restricciones que tenemos.
Por un lado, -5 debe ser menor o igual
que "x" menos 4
y por el otro lado "x" menos 4
debe ser menor o igual que 13.
Así que esto nos da dos restricciones
que debe satisfacer esta "x".
Y lo más sencillo que podemos hacer en este
momento es separar esta desigualdad en 2,
por un lado vamos a tener que -5
es menor o igual que "x" menos 4
y al mismo tiempo...
y al mismo tiempo se debe satisfacer que "x"
menos 4 sea menor o igual que 13.
Así que estas dos desigualdades se deben
cumplir al mismo tiempo,
así que esencialmente
si lo quieres ver como conjunto,
estamos intersectando
la solución de este con la solución de esta otra.
Así que vamos a resolver por separado,
ok y ya después vamos a recordar que tenemos aquí una palabra muy importante que es la conjunción "y".
Muy bien, entonces resolvamos ésta primero
para ir despejando la "x"
pues podemos  sumar de ambos lados 4,
sumamos 4 de ambos lados
y aquí me queda 9...
perdón, no es 9, es -5 más 4 es -1,
es menor o igual que "x" menos 4 más 4,
estos se cancelan y me queda "x".
Así que "x" es mayor o igual que -1
ó si lo quieren ver de esta forma,
"x" es mayor o igual que -1,
aquí nos dice -1 menor o igual que "x",
estas dos son equivalentes realmente verdad,
muy bien, entonces esto es por un lado,
por el otro ¿qué es lo que tenemos?
que "x" menos 4 es menor o igual que 13,
nuevamente puedo sumar 4 de ambos lados,
así que del  lado izquierdo estos se cancelan
y me queda que "x" es menor o igual
que 13 más 4 que son 17...
17...
Muy bien, y hay que recordar que tenemos la palabra "y",
esto quiere decir que se deben cumplir ambos,
entonces esto lo podemos ya reescribir,
digamos incluso como una desigualdad compuesta
como que -1 es menor o igual que "x",
pero esa misma "x", debe ser menor o igual...
debe ser menor o igual que 17.
Muy bien, entonces,
¿cómo se vería el conjunto solución
ya de estas dos desigualdades digamos, conjuntas?
ok... tengo una línea muy grande...
Digamos que por aquí anda el 17,
por acá anda el 18...
quien sabe que hay aquí en medio,
pero aquí está el 0, aquí anda el -1, el -2, ok...
y bueno, por supuesto entre 0 y 17
hay muchas otras cosas,
pero bueno, con eso me basta
para ejemplificar esto.
Lo primero que podemos hacer es ver que "x"
debe ser mayor o igual que -1,
entonces si puede ser -1
y nos tomamos todos los que están a la derecha,
ok, pero no puede ser tan grande...
ok... ahora sí...
No puede ser tan grande porque
también me dice que "x" debe ser menor o igual que 17.
Ok, entonces, aquí están todos
los que están por arriba de -1
pero que también están por abajo de 17,
así que este segmento es
nuestro conjunto solución,
y si quisiéramos expresarlo
en términos de intervalos,
pues en realidad vamos de -1 a 17
y ponemos esto...
este... estos corchetes
ya que si estamos incluyendo -1
y también estamos incluyendo a 17,
entonces ya tienes una buena noción de que son
los problemas de desigualdades compuestas,
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo.
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo y
vamos a hacer uno un poquito más... más difícil,
pero es la misma idea
que hemos estado haciendo.
El problema dice que -12 es menor que 2
menos "5x" que es menor o igual que 7.
Entonces lo primero que puedes notar
es que aquí hay un menor
y aquí hay un menor o igual,
eso va a dar soluciones un poco distintas
cada vez que resolvamos este tipo de problemas,
pero la idea es esencialmente igual,
podemos tomarnos esta primera desigualdad
y podemos resolver por aparte
ésta otra morada.
Muy bien, entonces lo que tenemos
es que -12 es menor que 2 menos "5x"
y también tenemos otra desigualdad,
tenemos la desigualdad morada que se debe
satisfacer al mismo tiempo que la verde.
La morada nos dice que 2 menos "5x"
es menor o igual que 7,
entonces estas dos desigualdades
se deben cumplir al mismo tiempo
y lo que vamos a hacer
es resolverlas por separado,
y ver cómo es el conjunto solución
de ambos.
Muy bien, entonces
para ir despejando la "x",
lo primero que uno puede hacer
es restar 2 de ambos lados,
restamos dos de ambos lados,
¿y qué es lo que me queda?
-12 menos 2 es -14,  esto es menor que,
estos se cancelan y me queda "-5x".
Muy bien, entonces ahora
para despejar la "x"
lo que podemos hacer es
dividir todo entre -5, pero...
pero hay que tener mucho cuidado porque
estaríamos dividiendo entre un número negativo
y ya sabemos que si multiplicamos
o dividimos por un número negativo,
la desigualdad se invierte,
cambia de sentido.
Entonces, si dividimos entre -5
tendremos -14 entre -5
y aquí tendremos simplemente "x", verdad,
"-5x" entre -5 pues es "x"
y la desigualdad ya no es un menor que,
ahora va a ser un mayor que.
Y entonces -14 entre -5 es mayor que "x",
¿quién es esto?
Esto por ejemplo expresado
en términos de...
ehhh... número compuesto,
es decir, un número con una fracción,
estos son 2 enteros 4/5 y es positivo porque
tenemos menos entre menos que es más.
Entonces 2 enteros 4/5 es mayor que "x",
esta es mi primera solución.
Ahora vamos a ver que pasa
del lado derecho.
Aquí nuevamente podemos restar 2 de ambos lados,
de hecho, podríamos restar 2 en conjunto,
es decir, hacerlo simultáneo,
sin embargo puede eso llegar a confundir y...
y no es bueno para nadie
que nos confundamos,
así que yo te sugiero que siempre
separes primero la desigualdad en dos distintas
y de aquí obtenemos que "-5x" verdad,
restamos 2 justo para cancelar esto,
"-5x" es menor o igual que 7 menos 2,
que es 5.
Si dividimos todo entre -5,
aquí vamos a tener "x" y 5 entre -5 es -1,
pero otra vez, dividimos entre
un número negativo,
por lo tanto, la desigualdad se invierte y en vez de ser un menor o igual, se vuelve un mayor o igual.
Así que ya tenemos nuestras dos soluciones
"x" debe ser mayor o igual que -1
y al mismo tiempo...
al mismo tiempo debe ser más chico que 2 enteros 4/5.
Entonces, si lo ponemos en términos de un...
de un este... de un intervalo,
lo que tenemos es que va de -1 a 2 4/5
donde el -1 si lo estamos incluyendo,
pero el 2 enteros 4/5 no,
esto es estrictamente mayor,
no puede ser igual,
así es que en términos de intervalo así se expresaría
o bien, que -1 es menor o igual que "x",
que es menor...
que de hecho es menor estricto...
es menor estricto que 2 enteros 4/5, muy bien...
ok... esto es un 4...
Perfecto, entonces, estas dos cosas son equivalentes,
vamos a ver cómo se vería en la recta numérica...
si nosotros aquí tenemos nuestra recta...
por ejemplo que aquí anda...
anda -1 y por acá está el 2 enteros 4/5...
por supuesto aquí anda el 0, el 1, en fin...
pero bueno, con estas dos cosas me basta.
Me dice que "x" es mayor o igual que -1,
donde si puede ser -1 y nos tomamos todos estos,
todos estos, hasta llegar al 2 enteros 4/5,
pero éste no puede ser...
ese no puede ser, no lo estamos incluyendo,
así que...
así es como se grafica mi conjunto solución.
Y bueno, estos son problemas que han sido
utilizando la conjunción "y".
Hagamos ahora un ejemplo en donde usemos
la palabra o la conjunción "o".
Digamos que tenemos el conjunto de desigualdades
"4x" menos 1 es mayor o igual que 7
y aquí vamos a utilizar la palabra "o"...
o que se cumple que "9x"
sobre 2 es menor que 3.
Entonces estas desigualdades deben ser "o",
es decir, la "x" es válida si satisface esta desigualdad
o si satisface esta desigualdad o si satisface ambas, podría llegar a suceder.
Entonces vamos a ver cual es el conjunto solución,
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es resolver cada una de éstas
y el "o" va a decir que vamos
a unir las soluciones.
Muy bien, entonces, para ir despejando "x",
podemos sumar 1...
1 de ambos lados y entonces
¿qué me queda aquí?
Que "4x" es mayor o igual
que 7 más 1 que es 8,
de donde si pasamos el 4 dividiendo "x"
es mayor o igual que 2,
verdad,  es decir,
dividimos entre 4 de ambos lados
y aquí se cancela y 8 entre 4 es 2 y
no tenemos que cambiar el signo de la desigualdad
porque es positivo.
Ok, entonces tenemos que "x"
es mayor o igual que 2...
Muy bien... y... o más bien,
se debe cumplir eso o que "9x" entre 2 es menor que 3,
podemos multiplicar
por 2/9 de ambos lados...
por 2/9 de ambos lados,
aquí por supuesto que el 2 se cancela con éste,
el 9 con éste y lo que me queda del lado izquierdo
es que "x" es menor que 3 por 2 sobre 9,
si cancelamos aquí este 3 con un 3 del 9,
me queda que "x"...
que "x" es menor que 2/3.
Muy bien, entonces "x" es menor
que 2/3 y al mismo...
o se deben más bien...
"x" es menor que 2/3 ó es mayor que...
mayor o igual que 2.
Muy bien, entonces vamos a ver cómo se ve esto,
yo sé que puede llegar a ser confuso a veces,
pero ya cuando lo grafiquemos va
a ser mucho más claro, por ejemplo,
si aquí tenemos el 0, aquí el 1,
aquí anda el 2 y acá anda el 3, en fin...
aquí a lo mejor anda el -1,
¿qué se yo...?
Entonces, nuestro...
nuestra solución de la primera es,
nos tomamos el 2,
lo incluimos y partir de ahí nos vamos
hacia la derecha, muy bien.
Y de la otra solución,
tenemos que "x" es menor que 2/3...
ok, "x" es menor que 2/3 que aquí anda,
el 2/3 no lo incluimos y nos vamos todo hacia
la izquierda...
Entonces, como realmente me está diciendo
que la "x" es mayor o igual que 2
ó "x" es menor que 2/3,
en realidad estos dos conjuntos forman toda la solución,
muy bien, ya sea que estemos de este lado
o de este otro lado, es válido.
Y eso es bastante interesante porque en cualquiera...
en cualquiera de estos conjuntos tenemos solución,
verdad, en el rojo o en el verde.
Si hubiéramos utilizado la palabra "y" en lugar de "o",
no tendríamos solución, verdad,
no puede ser mayor o igual que 2 y al mismo
tiempo menor que 2/3, son ajenos estos conjuntos.
Así que la única razón por la que hay solución
es porque usamos la palabra "o" para...
para cumplir cualquiera de estos...
cualquiera de estas dos condiciones.
Así que espero que te haya resultado esto
bastante divertido.